when i was 10 years old we traveled from
colorado to new jersey to visit
relatives
at christmas time
we did a host of a variety of things i
actually got to see the original cast
and the wiz and did a lot of sightseeing
but one of my favorite moments was to
stay up late at night and wait till
everyone else had gone to bed and then i
would sneak downstairs to watch
television
a host of old movies that probably had
no business watching such as bonnie and
clyde and
oklahoma that was a little okay
but i remember one evening come across a
show
it was an old movie and
it must have been white christmas or
holiday inn of that type but it was a
musical
and i um started watching and then they
started to do this musical scene
and i noticed i saw bing crosby in
blackface
and i i was confused i couldn't quite
understand
what the blackface had to do with the
singing and dancing
that was my introduction to blackface
minstrelsy
blackface minstrelsy originated in new
york and not the south as a lot of
people would think
in the 1830s
it was an incident where white actors
would blacken their faces with burnt
cork
paint on bright red lips
um exaggerate the whites of their eyes
and put on a tightly coiled wig to
create characters of african americans
on the american stage
the typical minstrel show was a parody
of black culture song and dance and
speech
interspersed with stump speeches jokes
musical interludes and theatrical skits
the cast included a roster of recurring
characters the interlocutor acted as the
mc
you had mr tambo and mr bones
as the end men
then you also had characters like the
clownish slave jim crow which was also
the name of the jim crow laws that we
knew in the american south
or the maternal mammy
a hyper-sexualized winch
an arrogant dandy zip [ __ ] and the lazy
childish [ __ ]
the caricatures were often brutal
but not to the white audiences who
laughed at the antics of the illiterate
slaves as they sat secure in their own
superiority
the image of the dancing simple-minded
buffoons captured the public's
imagination and spread across the
country like wildfire
blackface minstrelsy grew to be the most
popular form of american entertainment
in the 19th century
abraham lincoln and mark twain spoke
highly of the american minstrel show
applauding the characterizations and the
source of its humor
but just as it entertained it also
dehumanized the subjects of its ridicule
leaving the abolitionist frederick
douglass to describe blackface minstrels
as quote the filthy scum of white
society who have stolen from us a
complexion denied them by nature
ironically after the civil war
african americans forged their own
careers on the professional stage the
route to success often meant
appropriating the mass that was used to
mock them
white audiences also embrace black
performance in their local communities
these amateur minstrels used
instructional guides that provided them
with jokes routines
songs and costumes they needed to put on
their own shows
such was the habit of politicians
fraternal orders colleges high schools
and community performances who carried
on this tradition well into the 20th
century
the professional minstrel show left an
indebtable imprint on the american
psyche
the images and racial stereotypes that
continue to circulate in american
society on sheet music magazines books
vaudeville theater film television radio
records
and all kinds of formats
these stereotypes were powerful
reinforcement of the ideas of white
supremacy and black inferiority
the news headlines of the last few
months have shown us that the legacy of
blackface minstrelsy continues to haunt
us
in a survey conducted by the pew
research center they found that one in
three americans say that blackface is
always
or sometimes okay if it's used in a
halloween costume
so let me ask this question
what is the appeal of darkening one's
skin in order to impersonate someone of
a different race
blackface minstrelsy was born out of the
realities of slavery and racial
segregation
and it's a continual reappearance echoes
the pain and suffering felt by black
people whose bodies and cultures were
presented as strange and grotesque
it is a persistent reminder of the
racism and prejudices that bred its very
existence
the way it infiltrated society is a
clear example of how deeply ingrained
racism is in this country
and the racial subjugation embodied by
blackface minstrelsy and perpetuated
through a continuum of his history
is a form of aggression
a psychic wound that refuses to heal
racial impersonation of any form cannot
escape this legacy
so it's time to shift the power of
representation
to develop more expansive narratives
about the rich complexity of who we are
as human beings
acknowledging and recognizing blackface
for what it is and what it symbolizes is
a step in the right direction
educating ourselves and how stereotypes
reinforce racist ideologies is another
success in either case depends on an
honest self-assessment of our social and
cultural biases and how they came to be
the legacy of blackface minstrelsy is
our shared history and requires
all of us to take collective
responsibility in dismantling its power
to oppress and humiliate
the next time you're confronted with
someone in blackface or see a racist
stereotype
tell me
what will you do
thank you